former FBI agent Bob Levinson was last
seen more than a decade ago
he is the longest held hostage in
American history the US government
believes he's being held in Iran this
week Levinson's family stepped up
pressure on the Iranian government jeff
Begay spoke with Levinson's family you
referred to this as a fight why do you
call it a fight this is a fight we have
been fighting for 12 and a half years to
get my father home to us we know the
Iranian regime is responsible for
kidnapping him you have no doubt we have
no doubt whatsoever sera Levinson
Moriarty believes Iran still has not
revealed all that it knows about her
father Robert Levinson a former FBI
agent vanished in 2007 the FBI believes
he was captured on iran's Kish Island
while on a mission for the CIA
this April 2011 photo of Levinson in an
orange jumpsuit still gives his family
hope that eight years later he is
fighting and staying strong last month
when the Iranian government admitted in
a United Nations filing that Levinson's
case was ongoing the family saw that as
a ray of hope we believe it's very
significant what do you think it shows
it shows exactly what we've believed all
along which is that the Iranians took
him back in March of 2007 and that they
have the ability to send him home to us
the reward for information leading to
the 71 year olds return has been
increased to 25 million dollars Sara
believes the reward and president
Trump's Twitter messages demonstrate
that the US government is engaged on the
issue people want to bring Bob Levinson
home and we're so thankful for that and
we believe that if anyone's going to be
able to do it it's president Trump Bob
Levinson is a large family across the
country pressing for his return a wife
seven children and nine grandchildren
who's that in the picture I'm grandpa
Bob including six-year-old Sean who is
looking forward to a reunion what do you
think he's gonna think of you
um I think he's gonna think I'm a little
awesome
[Laughter]
in October Robert O'Brien became the
president's national security adviser
when he worked in the State Department
he led diplomatic efforts on hostage
related matters and worked closely with
the Levinson family further evidence
Sara Moriarty hopes that the White House
is working to bring her father home or
CBS this morning Saturday Jeff Pegues in
Washington